[Music]
just soda letting it lenin part of it
tomorrow way but yeah I worked out at
3:16 when I ain't back in 384 18 2006 I
was 14 I started boxing yeah I lost I
got dumped like I was stuck at 370 and
that was the one the arrows or stuff I
was about 370
[Music]
probably 11 years
[Music]
leave a tenth of the HOV way right -
[ __ ] strategy she said I went I
cheated on one time I got a Groupon for
cupping and I went over here and it was
horribly I'm saying he's way better do
you do the coffee shop and that's the
first thing I do when I walk needs to be
smaller
yes purposely purposely that's seen as
ever wanna see that's that purple
special
just the blood Scott yes I get it spot
clap that join you on a plane you keep
walking around yeah oh [ __ ]
you came at a good night we got the
stars of debt we got the death of stars
we got everything tonight we got farts
oh [ __ ] we'll hit you with an oldie but
a goodie
I will let settlement [ __ ] duel
[ __ ] we got two different types
of weed the one I juice back with the
missing lately I'm saying this will kill
you and then we got a container this
[ __ ] I don't know what the [ __ ] this is
we're gonna smoke this till it's over
we got the earthquake we we got Stars we
got a liquid acid everything you need to
take it to that next level psychology
you got a liquid asset so I can make tea
you know English people here hey don't
be making tea [ __ ]
[Music]
that's how we [ __ ] podcast [ __ ]
uncle Joey here said tighten it's gonna
be a good night if you're under 18 hang
up now I don't want no drama with your
mother this is not for you to be we got
everything we got my sugar the pills we
got purple stars we got [ __ ] red
stars
I got a container this [ __ ] 45 look
at this we got a [ __ ] no label this
is not good breaking this is as they say
in the street no bueno you know I'm
saying we got same everybody not to
mention your uncle [ __ ] Joey
and his little Jewish friend of debt
police I act please ready for 10 stars
tonight and so am I it's that type of
[ __ ] mate I had the flu for a few
days so now I gotta kill that [ __ ]
German I'm saying the way you've called
me another mine's name when I'm trying
to make love to you boom down the hatch
no drama
give it to me I'll give it oh [ __ ] I'm
like a [ __ ] snake you ever see the
snake when you see the whole star pass
through all right
if you ain't [ __ ] laughing you're
crying who gives a [ __ ] they go Leone
lucky for and there's a lucky five oh
[ __ ]
200 apiece and here comes another for
action there you go we're going deep
into the murky waters looking ship
please stop you're not a black top that
tell you
episode 500 I took him in the afternoon
yeah I blacked out about the court by
8:15 and I came to you know I'm in my
dream yeah I wake up the P in the room
is purplish I see Smurfs what the [ __ ]
we're going deep don't stop till you get
enough [ __ ] you know I'm Sayla so
he stays here till 2:00 so when I call
my goalie Tony he'll fall asleep till
4:00 and I kept thinking why do you fall
asleep before I was onstage you mean
like like listen guys I blacked out it
was still a great show to the tape I was
like holy [ __ ] I remember being on stage
at the stage I start talking about why
the guys fought on the plane which
rocked the plane now yeah because he
took an early flight you get up early
sometimes honey an Iowan I have to
digest yeah I got up at 5:00 I'll take a
tremendous [ __ ] at about 6:20 by 6:20
after I have the cup of coffees are two
piece of nicotine gum two or three buns
oh let's say if I get up at 5:00 right I
won't [ __ ] till 6:00 26:30 right but if
you're gonna for fun take a flight that
means you take him a 7:00 a.m. flight
and you're at the airport
you're not gonna [ __ ] one of those
airports okay how bad you need this [ __ ]
when you walk into the airport you smell
that squirrel of shits you won't go in
there I only got in the family I pull
any only go to family bathrooms any
other
I don't give a Frenchman's [ __ ] where's
your family they got lost
I'm [ __ ] I'm think they got taken I
have no idea yeah we're just in here I
use the family bathroom but if I take
candid the family bathroom what type of
animal takes the [ __ ] on the plane so I
wait but but you get those three parts
on the plane that means this shit's
closed the [ __ ] and the fights gonna
come another come from fresh fresh from
the roots and thick the little vacuum it
kills it over here
but this guy over here gets a mouthful
of these sleeping because it just
inhales the whole fart if you wanna play
that you test of a pipette just blow to
the smoke down and you see it the smoke
gets gathered in the corner this vacuum
is in the corners of those planes yeah
so you got gonna play if you want to be
a [ __ ] junkie just take the window
seat take a long sweatshirt and hit the
[ __ ] on the flight last week thought I
was [ __ ] petrified I was watching the
movie I had one of these happy pills and
man [ __ ] had a couple stars it was like
I took a 6:45 flight yeah from st. Louis
and I was sitting there like I was in my
own house [ __ ] I'm on a [ __ ] plane
home and the guy was looking at me I got
upgraded and it was just it was just two
rows the first class so the guy over
here was checking me out I turn the
right he doesn't even rat me out thank
God
cuz those people are planes or rats
don't write you if not the bus it goes
long for the other I left to buzz off on
version there's a buzz in the bathroom
you smoke a vapor clean the bathroom
that Buzzle [ __ ] yeah what's going on
here they go you smoked me it was the
same I go I'm gonna figure out I was
using the toilet and then the plane
shift and I hit the wall and they were
like okay and I sat down I heard I hit
the vapor pen because I thought don't
gonna arrest me where I landed yep not a
soul it is he uncle Joey not even an
American flag you ready for Bonnie yeah
[ __ ] yeah we're going deep deep deep in
the murky waters on the launch day he
understand me
cuz if you're not [ __ ] tip-top but go
on the Lord's Day how you gonna be on
Wednesday gonna be a [ __ ] mess will
you still over there
got about six more stars coming to you
it's a big night 3000 and how long were
you two days we have a high tolerance to
the [ __ ] stars of debts
[Music]
I guess outside does you're fired up a
[ __ ] sports me no no no single over
here he was the quanto fee did you do
this [ __ ]
Lee you ready for a bong video that's
the [ __ ] mule of death that bone
right there
you're looking good tonight [ __ ]
don't forget Wednesday at 8:00 Saturday
night 9:00 o'clock the Borgata it's
already sold out but they're releasing
140 tickets tomorrow so if you want to
get tickets just sit tight
oh yeah that's what we do here in the
church listen to this [ __ ] guitar are
you kidding me or what
when I first heard this in the [ __ ]
sixth grade I almost jumped out my
window headfirst through the [ __ ] air
conditioning you ready Lee you want to
do some of that or you want new one
finish that finish that was Lisa
upscale type Judy's body there's a
length of [ __ ] black stuff here we go
[Music]
[Music]
with your music
he's not for fan you can tell this is
something please and I prefer lilo
something
[Music]
I love a thousand times I have a hard I
tried heartbreak girl your time has come
can't change your evil way are you
[ __ ] nuts or what it's just a sixth
grader I'm gonna flop an old geezer
listen to this out it's a [ __ ]
classic you gotta be upset
top that out of all time heartbreak
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
please gotta cook nightshirt on select
the shoes my collection looking good
tonight
he's got no spots box they get spots and
Barnabas oh let's do this [ __ ] do this
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
tremendous when you got Bond stuff on
you you're doing the right job
here we go livin lovin on a Sunday night
who loves you more than me if you're
Nadine get the [ __ ] outta here
[ __ ]
go play with a GI Joe some way you
little [ __ ]
[Music]
what do you wanna do you want to sit
down like a bumpy they're gonna watch
the church what's happened now there's
no Dancing with the Stars there's
nothing you know what tape 60 minutes
I love 60 minutes if I'm watching let's
do one more bond get get this [ __ ]
podcast started and that's it that stay
get you [ __ ] a nice little podcast
Monday morning you got some delicious
[Music]
there's no [ __ ] stories about what we
can't do we do it all we do it up how
are you gonna live for get out of the
trailer take a chance
Columbus big [ __ ] it's Sunday
night this is your lucky we got the
world by the balls and myself in the
morning do a bucket and do your jumping
jacks and get out there and do your
[ __ ] job [ __ ] anyway
you know I love you I tell you about the
book
[Music]
[Music]
it's gonna be a good show tonight you
don't worry about nothing relax grab a
pint you might learn something here I'm
safe and there ain't no holding back kid
[Music]
you know what man everybody wants to be
socially acceptable spin that [ __ ] [ __ ]
it who gives a [ __ ] about being accepted
spin that [ __ ] on these [ __ ]
they won't know what to do you're
sitting there going Joey spin that [ __ ]
I have no idea what you're talking about
take a body I'll get back to you later
[ __ ] bondage for Jerry's kids
youtube.com slash c / Joey Diaz that's
the place to be if you don't go there in
ten minutes
it's like if you put ranch with your
wings go [ __ ] your mommy understand me
stay black uncle Joey loves you and I'll
see you guys at ten
[Music]